the house with a clock in its walls was
directed by Eli Roth and stars Jack
Black and Kate Blanchette and is the
story of a young orphan named Lewis who
after a tragedy moves in with his uncle
who he learns is a warlock searching for
a clock trapped within the walls of his
house that has the power to bring about
the end of the world
I'm sorry this review is so late for one
my wife and I went on vacation for our
anniversary and then as soon as I got
back I got extremely sick and I am still
sick I have really bad cold and my voice
is really messed up and I'm gonna power
through this review anyway I went and
saw this with my friend last night and I
brought a stack of napkins into the
theater like this big by the end of the
movie I had used all of them so I am
just a bucket of filth right now and
we're gonna get through this review and
have fun
Eli Roth up until now has been primarily
known for horror films or rated R films
very gory films and so this is a bit of
a departure for him a PG rated family
movie and I was very surprised to see
him in pretty much top form here I've
never been a huge fan of Eli Roth's
movies and this is probably my favorite
one of his I think that he has brought
something to this film that allows it to
be a little boundary-pushing in regards
to what can be in a PG rated family
horror film because there's some imagery
in this movie that I can see a lot of
kids being very disturbed by this could
have an effect that Large Marge in
pee-wee's big adventure had on kids or
certain other Disney films that have
very frightening moments this isn't a
Disney film but it is definitely one
aimed at families and I can tell you
that when I bought my ticket the theater
the manager looked at me and my friend
he was like dude just so you know like
four kids ran out of that theater today
crying for myself those types of
experiences were very integral to me as
a kid in discovering film in my love of
film whenever I saw something that did
actually disturb me when I was young I
was fascinated by it maybe at first I
didn't didn't want to look at it but
then later I wanted to and I wanted to
know more about this subject I was a
weird little kid who liked that type of
entertainment I liked being scared I was
fascinated by haunted houses Halloween
was interesting to me
scary stuff was in
twisting and this film is aimed at young
children like that who other people
might consider weird a major theme of
the film is that being weird is great
Cate Blanchett's character says that
it's the nuts and her cookies that make
them special and that's kind of what the
message behind the film is is that if
you are unique different kind of strange
that's great
embrace that and if the end result is
that some parents are upset because the
film is a little bit boundary pushing
for the PG rating well that's gonna
happen most of the films that impacted
me when I was a kid were films that
perhaps should not have been PG like
jaws or Raiders of the Lost Ark or
Temple of Doom which kind of helped
catapult the eventual pg-13 rating into
existence the production design of the
film is one of the best parts it takes
place in the 50s and it definitely has
an aesthetic that tributes those old
fashioned horror films of that time
period it feels almost like a
feature-length episode of are you afraid
of the dark or the goosebumps TV show
but just given a much better treatment
in regards to big-budget territory it
feels like the type of entertainment
that I would like to have seen more of
coming out of the 90s when we had such
great horror for kids in the 90s and on
television the performances were very
good I like Jack Black quite a bit in
this role Cate Blanchett as always was
magnificent
Kyle McLaughlin who I did not know was
in the film was a nice surprise the
young boy Owen Vacarro really good stuff
I mean in all honesty I can't believe
how surprised I was watching the film
because I had no expectations going in
but it's a type of movie that it
consistently builds a sense of actual
suspense but it's fun you know you're
able to have a good time with it because
you recognize it has that PG rating but
with Eli Roth behind the camera there is
something about it that feels like it's
pushing it to the point where you have a
sense of uncertainty towards what they
could actually get away with
unfortunately though there's humor
spread about throughout the film that
feels almost like it was contractually
obligated or something there's random
poop jokes and one towards the end
involving a character getting shrunk
down that worked for like a second and
then it was just way too long but the
poop jokes I don't really understand
there are so many and the film seems to
think they are really funny and they're
just not it was almost a rolling it was
almost like hey you were at sort of a
higher level than I expected you to be
and now you have a cat tree pooping
that's so funny it's just kind of old
but I also recognized it as a film that
is already far scarier than most PG
films for kids you have to have moments
where they laugh and feel a little safe
but as an adult it just took me out of
the film I haven't liked too many of Eli
Roth's films so I didn't know what to
expect going in and I feel like he kind
of revitalized himself with this picture
and his next film on his IMDB it also
involves a group of children that's
possibly attached with Jim Carrey so I
don't know if that'll be pg-13 R rated R
or PG but I would love to see what else
he can do with this type of film I'm
gonna give the house with the clock and
its walls Abbey also I do want to give
one more special thank you to Wix please
do check out this link in the
description below to learn more about
how you can create your own website and
a very simple and easy to use way they
have so many creative tools and their
editor is very easy to use and I had a
lot of fun doing it guys thank you so
much as always for watching I actually
got through this without having to use
these tissues even once so I feel pretty
good about that
thanks guys as always look forward to
more reviews very soon if you like this
you can click right here and get stuff
mine eyes
you
[Music]